cam newton also has appeared recently on
the im athlete podcast speaking with
fred taylor and brandon marshall
one of the things he he mentioned and
let's not spend a whole lot of time on
this because i think we got a better
topic coming up right
he he said that that that when he missed
time with covet 19 it kind of screwed up
his whole season
i looked there were reports that the
team thought he may have had brain fog
he denied that
all sorts of lingering effects of of
covet 19
and look i i
i it had to have derailed his season
just from the standpoint of the rhythm
and the flow of it
but if it does affect a quarterback in
any way in a cognitive manner
yeah that's gonna screw you up if you're
trying to perform at the highest
possible level without a doubt
you know again it was a guy that hey
they had built some momentum
and we're building something you know he
recognized and he said this after the
fact
he didn't know as much as the offense as
he thought he did
you know early on in the year he was
kind of kind of you know faking it to a
degree
he realized he knew some things but he
didn't understand the whole scope
so now you're sick you're dealing with
that okay and you're not able to
again continue increase the learning of
the offense and everything like that
and then on top of that hey within
learning a new offense
hey there's certain mechanics you're
thinking about as a quarterback oh okay
okay
josh mcdaniel called this play all right
you know oh wait i got to take five
steps my first reach here the second
hitch i'm gonna throw over here and do
that okay
and now you're not even getting to
practice the physical aspects
of the mental gymnastics of knowing the
offense if that made sense
but that is part of being a quarterback
because you got to kind of tie that all
together
and i do think and it showed right from
the get-go his first game back was what
the denver bronco game right
the denver bronco game you know he
missed
easy slam dunk throws that a guy like
him had not missed and he certainly
wasn't throwing the ball the same way he
was
like we saw him on c in seattle on
sunday night football on nbc where he
was throwing dimes all over the field
and everything like that
so it did take him out of the rhythm of
what he was doing it took the team out
of the rhythm of how they were playing
football
because they had to adjust and play a
different way
with brian hoyer and you know then
at quarterback there in that kansas city
chiefs game and things like that so
i do believe that really threw him off
his mark and kind of ruined the rhythm
of their offense and everything they
were building at that time
yeah and uh and again you
i don't think we'll know for years the
extent to which that
that disease affects the people who who
survive it you know
i was having this conversation yesterday
with my wife that somebody says only 99
you know 99 of people who get it live
well yeah but it but it still affects
you in some way
right it's not something you know for
the ones who have the symptoms there are
impacts that we still don't fully
understand and it
it's just this this full body mess that
you can become
even if you do survive it and i think if
you're trying to be a professional
athlete performing
at the highest possible level with the
kind of commitment and
and uh dedication and stress and
everything that goes along with it i i
i can't imagine it didn't affect cam
newton in some way all right you know
wait last thing i was gonna say too just
because i i know we'll jump in it but
you know again too let's not lose
reality here
you know if he played we saw that kansas
city game
i mean they had kansas city under ropes
that's one of those things where i think
you and i would agree if he was out
there it looked like one of those days
you'd go the patriots are gonna
they're gonna beat the chiefs you know
they lose you know they they lose that
broncos game
they get blown out by the 49ers the week
after that but they also did go seven
and nine
and lost some heartbreaking losses too
where
it wasn't like they were not
non-competitive and not
you know making teams sweat a little bit
and i think that's been lost a little
bit in translation with with cam newton
at starting quarterback too even though
it wasn't the prettiest from his
standpoint
and you know at one point late in the
year shefty suggested there was no way
that cam newton would be with the
patriots in 2021 the way that newton
talked in that podcast with fred taylor
and brandon marshall i think it sounds
like he's willing
there's nothing he's willing there's a
chance um i i don't think
i don't think that's a that's a closed
door yet i still think there's a
possibility he could come back and end
up being the starting quarterback
for the new england patriots i think
money's a huge issue because he only got
3.7 million for all of last year and to
the extent that he'd kind of want a
little retroactive
something for what he put in last year
and what he got out as a starting
quarterback all year long that that
could be an impediment we'll do a draft
later in the program
of cam newton potential destinations but
you cannot you cannot remove
the new england patriots from the list
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports